oh my god good my main inspiration and
resource was a gentleman by the name of
Jeff glass Benner he is an amputee and
he is an extraordinary human being I
cold called him tracked him down
introduced myself to him I flew him to
set this man that I want to introduce is
the inspiration for the character of
will that I'm playing is the first
American amputee to climb Mount Everest
he is a three-time Paralympian he is
also a world champion wheelchair
basketball player and he is also for
this character my greatest inspiration
so ladies and gentlemen team skyscraper
there's a proud day for all of us and an
honor today for all of us to have Jeff
onto that for the very first time part
of the reasons why I think this movie is
so cool
because you're gonna have an amputee
there's gonna show people that is
kick-ass to be an amputee it's okay that
you can get to any summit you can do
anything in life but you got to have it
in here then you got to have it in here
mr. Johnson studied the role and he
knows what it's like and some of the
struggles what it's like to be an
amputee
[Music]